la Corte Suprema de Justicia bloqueó los
planes de la administración de biden
para poner fin al título 42 política de
Trump que durante la pandemia permitía
la expulsión rápida de migrantes que
entraban a Estados Unidos de forma
ilegal con el argumento de salud pública
un juez Federal había dictaminado que el
título 42 se tenía que suspender la
semana pasada pero la acción de la Corte
Suprema extiende Una pausa que impuso
John Roberts magistrado de la Corte
Suprema para darle más tiempo
precisamente a la corte al tribunal
supremo de considerar el caso en esta
decisión de emergencia cinco jueces
conservadores se pusieron del lado de
los republicanos en 19 estados
incluyendo Texas y Arizona que buscaban
mantener el título 42 que se ha
utilizado para expulsar a migrantes más
de dos millones de veces desde que
empezó a implementarse en marzo del 2020
la decisión de la Corte Suprema mantiene
el estatus de bloquear la orden del juez
de distrito hasta que la Corte Suprema
entonces considerar el caso a fines de
febrero del 2023 que se espera se
pronuncie finalmente al respecto y
considere si los estados objetantes
tienen la capacidad legal para
intervenir en este caso